la musique française traditionnelle est
construite sur la langue française
évidemment l'accent tonique finale est
toujours fort on dit par exemple comme
j'avais beaucoup marché j'étais très
très fatiguée on appuie et et dans la
musique anglo saxonne qui est elle-même
naturellement autrement qu'à danser on a
tendance à dire pour dire cette phrase
on aurait dit l'accent tonique c'est sur
l'avant dernière note
c'est à dire comme j'avais beaucoup
marché la cabane au fond du jardin de
cabrel et quand cette évolution c'est
moi qui les fais d'ailleurs parce que en
france que je ne vous dis comme je vais
beaucoup marché est très très fatiguée
j'aperçois une ferme
je veux dire je m'arrête ici une chanson
de dylan bien lorsque j'ai traduit cette
chanson avec la collaboration de pierre
delanoë qui lui il n'avait pas beaucoup
dylan le pays de même pas du tout il
connaissait pas cette musique et il m'a
dit mais u
on ne peut pas dire comme j'avais
beaucoup marcher ça ne se dit pas c'est
pas un accent et beaucoup de gens ont
cru que quand cabrel dit la cabane au
fond du jardin
ces deux élections 2010 c'est pas vrai
c'est pas du tout l'accent du midi
c'est une américanisation du français
est aujourd'hui tout le monde fait ça
dans la chanson française et cette
révolution est très importante parce que
ça change complètement le concept
musical
[Musique]